that's what happens to people that
really get blown up they don't
follow any diversification rules and
they end up with one or two stocks
representing 40 50 60 percent of the net
worth and when they correct
they get killed in order to be
successful as an entrepreneur you need
to know
people there's nothing wrong with day
trading and i think there obviously
there's
over 20 million people doing it right
now just on robin hood alone so it's
been very successful platform
but that's not the same as investing
hi there mr wonderful here have you been
charged an overdraft fee this year
banks made a record high in overdraft
fees during the pandemics so maybe by
now
you're sick of paying monthly fees do
you know how banks use your money
when you make a deposit into a bank it
doesn't actually just sit there
banks are allowed to use 100 percent of
your money for investing or lending
this means that banks can and do use
your money to invest in fossil fuels
political
lobbying private prisons and gun
manufacturing just to name a few
aspiration does not like that or support
it
rest assured aspiration never lets your
money get invested into fossil fuel
projects
so how is aspiration different
aspiration is creating a financial firm
that
fights climate change and if you care
about sustainability
you should care about where you bank
aspiration is different than a typical
bank
but in some ways similar deposits are
still fdic
insured and they're regulated by finra
and use
529 bit encryption which basically means
your money is safe
the big difference is mission at the
core of aspiration is a sustainability
mandate
so join aspiration today and get an
aspiration debit card
become part of the movement so i want to
start by going back in time a little bit
when did you know that you were going to
be
rich did something happen when you were
a kid or did you always dream of being
rich
or was it just kind of luck
you know it was never the pursuit of
money that drove me
uh into entrepreneurship it was
it was the desire for personal freedom
because i had a rather
i'd call it traumatic experience when i
was young but really set me on the right
direction and
it was very simple i got one of my first
jobs in high school
and i i was at a shopping mall i'll
never forget the experience it was a
ice cream scooper so i was scooping ice
cream for people
and i got that job because the girl i
was interested in in high school was
across the mall in the shoe store
she was working there and i kind of
wanted to see if i could you know
you know stay close to her and see if we
could work things out and work go to
work together et cetera
so my first day on the job and she was
looking at
me from across you know right out the
other window
the owner of the store said to me look
see what happens when people sample ice
cream is they take their gum out and
they throw it on the floor
because you're getting a little sampler
on a little piece of wood
and so by the end of the day the floor
is completely black with gum plastered
all over it so she said to me listen
before you leave today
get down on your knees and scrape the
gum off the tile
and um and you have to do that every day
and and i
the this girl i was talking about was
watching me and i said
wait a second you hired me as a as an
ice cream scooper
not a gum scraper i mean i'm happy to
you know scoop i scream but i don't want
to get on my knees and wash the floor
and she said
you're going to do whatever i say i own
this store you're my employee um
you know if you and i said well i'm not
doing it i might my job description was
a scream scooper she said
well how about this you're fired and um
i didn't even know it fired meant but i
figured out pretty quickly and and that
was very
humiliating for me you had to ride my
bicycle home tell my mother what
happened
and so at that moment i realized
something very important it was a
big lesson in life for me that there's
two types of people in the world
there's people that own the store and
there's the people that
scrape the [ __ ] off the floor and you
have to kind of decide
which one you are and it doesn't mean
that being an employee is a bad thing
you can have a fantastic
life as being a great employee and
working for somebody and support your
family and everything else
but that's not for me i don't want
somebody telling me what to do
it's that simple and and that was the
beginning of my path
now the day i became wealthy was i never
saw it coming you know someone bought
our company for 4.2 billion dollars
the mattel toy company and and the 10 of
us that started it the next morning were
you know a huge liquidity event i didn't
stop working i've been working
ever since that day so you your success
in a big part was attributed because you
got a job
to impress or be with a girl and
because of what happened at your job
that was kind of your wow i can either
own the store or i can be the one
working at it
right that's basically what happened but
it was a very tough lesson because it
it really showed me the differences
between the pursuit of personal freedom
and and you know that that's what i
think
when i let guest lecture now to you know
graduating cohorts of engineers mostly i
tell them
you know it's never about money it has
nothing to do with money
personal freedom is is a burning desire
for many people
and the only way you can get that is to
achieve success
as an entrepreneur unless someone just
gives you
you know enough money to live freely i
don't know that's not easy to do
but to me it was the you know pursuit of
that freedom and then along the way
um i was very i was very fortunate and i
think
that's always been my burning desire i
want to be able to spend my time
doing the things i want to do i don't
you know one of the great outcomes of
entrepreneurship is the ability to
decide how to spend your time
and so i want to be doing this with you
today there's no reason i wouldn't
but if i didn't want to i don't have to
and that's the whole point of it that's
why i tell
you know young entrepreneurs understand
what the goal is it has nothing to do
with
with greed it has to do with personal
freedom i want to dive a little bit
deeper to your time in high school
because i want to know kind of who were
you in high school i know you used to
have a beard
which you no longer have maybe one day
he'll come back
but what kind of person were you in high
school well i also used to have hair and
i don't think that's coming back
so it's it's sort of i was uh you know i
wanted to pursue
uh photography and cinematography
and um you know be be a commercial
photographer and
film producer that's what i really
wanted to do and my stepfather said to
me look you're you're not good enough
in those fields they're highly
competitive you're probably going to
starve to death maybe you should pursue
a business degree this is after i
graduated from undergrad because
you know basically i spent my undergrad
in arts and psychology you know chasing
girls and
and doing what all college students do
have a great time but when i graduated
i really had nothing to show for it i
mean i'm happy to get a degree that's
great but it was not in a discipline
that i could
find a living or a formal living and so
he said look you should um
you should go and get a business degree
and then no matter what
discipline you pursue at least you'll
have the building blocks for business
it was great advice that was the next
path when i got out of business school
then i formed a television production
company and
i was able to start doing sports
programming for the networks
around the original six hockey teams in
new york detroit
you know uh boston etc and that company
was quite successful and we sold it and
then i
started the learning company next which
was called soft key first and then the
learning company and that's the one we
sold for 4.2 billion
so it's kind of a serendipitous path you
never know how it's going to turn out
on that point i think a big point of
debate now amongst a lot of people
is college and my question is
does college matter and the reason why
i'm asking is because i grew up
in a traditional indian house my parents
are immigrants from a state
called punjab and like a lot of indian
immigrants my parents always told me
that if you want to become successful
you have to become a doctor it's like
the uh
you know the path to wealth that's
that's what i was always taught
now for me i went through schooling i
don't use any of my degrees
but what what value does college have
nowadays does it still have the same
value it did when you were in college
well you know those those are great
observations you're making because i'll
tell you the truth i don't use my
degrees either i don't even remember
anything about what i took in my mba
it doesn't matter what what the value is
is the people i met
during that program ended up being very
important to me in my career
and i've always thought of education
really as as a
chance to to expand your contacts
either whether it's undergrad or you
know
graduate work is is that you're creating
a network a social network and in order
to
be successful as an entrepreneur you
need to know people
that can help you in different
disciplines and i and i never realized
that when i was going through it but i
don't remember anything
of you know some basic variable cost
analysis or something i i don't really
remember or care but i can tell you
my success in business had a lot to do
with the contacts i met there and when i
teach now
i recently taught a graduating class at
harvard just this week
and i told them the same lesson you know
the prof didn't like to hear that but
it's the truth i said it's the people
sitting beside you right now
some of you are virtual some of you
physically there that are going to be
the most important thing you get out of
this education not the actual
courseworker cases it's kind of you
real life will teach you that but the
contacts you have are extremely valuable
so i would argue that there is value
in in college there is value there but
while you're at it piss
you know pick a discipline i know your
parents told you doctor but i i told my
kids engineering
like i said to them look if you want a
great outcome for what you're borrowing
for
for college is engineering engineering
and engineering and if you have time at
night do some engineering
but it's sort of you know these days you
can artists are becoming very valuable
because of the digital economy so it's
always different for each generation
i want to go back to when you were
selling when you sold the learning
company for
four billion dollars because you said
you sold the company and now you finally
have some liquidity
so when you were building the company
i'm assuming
you must have had a lot of revenue to
sell the company for
billions of dollars when you made your
first one million dollars did you think
you were rich
you know it's it's a great question um
the way that happens and i've talked to
many other entrepreneurs that have had
big liquidity events
you know at the time the learning
company was acquired it was the largest
publisher of educational software in the
world
and it you know did business in i think
uh 46 countries and
we're the number one supplier for for
apple and schools and
all kinds of different products we had
hundreds of different products including
big titles like rita rabbit carmen san
diego oregon trail
mavis beacon i mean those are still out
in the markets today
when you're really passionate about what
you're doing you don't really
uh notice how this this this wealth
thing occurs because
you know i owned a lot of founders
shares i was one of the founding members
of the company
and one day you know they were turned
into cash through an acquisition
and i remember we all sat around the
next day and said what do we do i mean
we all just went back to work we didn't
know what else to do and so
it's so it's sort of um you know
provided for a lot of different things
for my family and everything else but
it's never been my motivation i mean i
don't do things i don't want to do and
luckily i've you know i've made plenty
of bad investments too
but um you know fortunately i know i
make enough good ones that
that i have all you know all i can use
and
i don't need more money i i want to do
things that uh
that i really enjoy and and that
provides me the ability to have
those opportunities and by the way now
i'm completely back into photography
again
i've got a you know guitar collection
that's absolutely huge i was actually a
shareholder of fender for a while
so i got my dreams in a reverse order
you know i wanted to be a rock star but
it took me a long time to get there
you're going to have to regrow the hair
man yeah i have to i have to do that but
it's really interesting you know i just
i do a lot of work with the guitar
companies now and i'm
you know i'm very big in watch
collecting and things that i really have
a passion for
that this uh this freedom provides me
especially nowadays we talk about
entrepreneurs making the first one
million dollars
and what does that i mean
when you make a million dollars i think
a lot of people have the kind of
misconception that oh
i made a million dollars now i must be
rich but for a lot of entrepreneurs
you make a million dollars all of the
million dollars goes right back into
your company because you want to grow it
bigger so is the way for someone to now
build a business and sell it or or how
do you now kind of uh
pull out some of the capital from a
business that that you're that you're
making money on
you know my mother taught me something
uh that i really didn't value until
later in life but she
as a young working woman in her 20s used
to take
20 of her paycheck and
she would invest it in two things telco
bonds because bucket back in those days
she said people would rather turn off
their heat than not be able to talk to
people
so so in those days those bonds would
produce six or seven percent
you know for five to seven year duration
and the other half was in dividend
paying s p
stocks and when she
you know she all through her working
career she just put 20 percent into that
and never took it out she lived off the
interest or the dividends
and what happened when she passed away i
was the older brother i became the
executor for the estate and the lawyer
called me downtown said listen
your mother died a very wealthy woman
and you're the executor and i said that
can't be
well she kept that account secret from
both of her husbands she was married
twice
you're kidding me and no and she did it
for herself and she i always wondered
how she could afford to take care of her
whole family and
put my brother and i through college and
you know all kinds of of uh
of just you know myopic focus on keeping
herself financially independent
and not even disclosing it to anybody
and when i called up
my brother and i said you can't believe
this she
her portfolio was very conservative but
over the 50 years that she had it it
grew immensely because she just
compounded those interest payments and
dividend yields
and that's the magic of you know what
i've learned in fact
there's a hundred million americans
today that do not have anything set
aside for their retirement in their 60s
and and that's one of the initiatives
i've started i have a a product called
bean stocks
to kind of emulate what my mother did
take you know some
a minimum of a hundred dollars a week
put it aside and we put it into indexes
and
etfs in the market and it grows with you
your whole life
if you want to end up in a good place
when you're 65
you need you know if you put 100 a week
aside in your early twenties you'll end
up with about a million five
million seven if the markets do what
they've done for over a hundred years
kind of give you six seven eight
nine percent you know returns each year
and they go up and down and everything
else but the point is you're constantly
putting that hundred bucks in a week
so beanstalks was my answer to that to
say look
this is something you do anyways even if
you're an entrepreneur you still have
that
that nest egg that you're putting aside
for and that's what my mother taught me
and i always had that i always
tried to put enough aside just in case
the poopoo hit the fan
that's that's a great point and it's a
great transition into
what i want to talk about next which is
how somebody young
who is now getting started into
investing because there's a lot of
people getting into the investing space
we've been seeing a massive
boom in the retail trading and investing
space
how should a young person invest their
money because your mother clearly
was big on dividend stocks things that
pay interest is that the best way to go
forward now for a young person
well there's a difference between day
trading and investing
there's nothing wrong with day trading
and i think there obviously there's
over 20 million people doing it right
now just on robin hood alone so it's
been very successful platform
but that's not the same as investing
it's very very difficult
over a long period of time to beat the
index when you're day trading because
you have
you know you tend to be concentrated on
just a very few names
and you're constantly trading them in
and out and i think it's fun in some
ways and nothing wrong with it but i
always tell people if you get
winnings from day trading take them and
put them in
to an index of some kind that you just
store away that you don't
risk you just let it sit there and grow
whether that's 10 or 15
whatever it is that's investing when you
do that
day trading is a form of gambling which
is really exciting and there's nothing
wrong with it i think it's
a wonderful thing that people do it but
it's not going to help you long term
because
very very very few people can beat the
indexes over a long period of time day
trading
so you're saying if somebody made a lot
of money off of the gamestop
saga take some of that money and put it
into an index that's gonna
help you make money for the long term
exactly that's the right strategy and
that's the right thing to do for
for your retirement you've got to have
that thing just compounding
you know get any one of the robo apps
and and
and do it that way because a trading
platform where you're picking a name
and you know day trading in and out is
very very difficult to grow wealth with
are you worried at all about the health
of the stock market because of
all the retail trading going on we have
so many people entering the stock market
maybe they know what they're doing maybe
they don't
but a lot of people are trading with
leverage i think we have the highest
margin trading
ever and a lot of people are coming into
the market with
very high expectations hoping to double
their money in a very short amount of
time
is the stock market going to crash
because of that
well markets always correct and
sometimes as much as 40 percent
i don't see that anytime soon because we
have a very very buoyant economy and
we're about to get
you know 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
package and now a room of a three
trillion dollar infrastructure package
that's a tremendous amount of stimulus
so you know asset classes like stocks
are likely to do well during that period
but there are times when markets do not
do well and you have to live through
that
i it doesn't bother me that you know
people are actively day trading
i have no problem with that i think that
you know is is just bringing more people
into the educational side of investing
and i'm not sure you know that we're
going to have a crash anytime soon
nobody knows
with certainty but my point is these are
environments that are very good and very
you know productive for stocks and so my
anticipation is they will tend to turn
higher
so what advice would you have for
someone who is new into the workforce
in their late 20s early 30s what should
they be doing
would you follow your mom's advice your
mother's advice of a 20
into the stock market into an etf or or
what would you recommend
well you know i i have some basic rules
i always say this never more than five
percent
in into any one stock so if you look at
a portfolio you never want one stock to
represent more than five percent of it
you never want a sector like energy or
technology to represent more than 20
percent of the portfolio
and have some allocation of fixed income
i'm currently 70
equities 30 fixed income because fixed
income is very expensive these days and
i anticipate as interest rates go up it
won't do that well but the point is it
provides stability
the whole idea of investing is
diversification you really want to be
diversified
and so i use exchange traded funds for
that that works for me
people can pick their own stocks if they
wish but you know there's all kinds of
different philosophies but
at the end of the day um you know if
you if you want to build a nest egg
you've got to have the discipline of
diversification
and and monitor your portfolio so that
no one position gets too big
that's what happens to people that
really get blown up they don't follow
any diversification rules and they end
up with one or two stocks
representing 40 50 60 percent of their
net worth and when they correct
they get killed can somebody still
follow the model today and become
wealthy i mean we're in an environment
where
a lot of people millennials especially
are are having a tough time
being able to pay their rent they're
having a tough time just be able to get
by
how does someone who's now essentially
living paycheck to paycheck
start putting aside money to invest and
become wealthy
do these kind of rules those of them
still apply today
they do because the the majority of
people and obviously there's exceptions
to every rule but
the majority of people spend too much
money on crap they don't need
i've noticed that for years and so i'm
very disciplined you know i
i don't buy clothes i don't need i don't
wear i learned that from my mother
my you know my i wear the same i've got
25 of these suits 25 of these ties 25 of
these shirts
i do a huge production run this is my
shark tank outfit i also wear it
all the time it's sort of the same i
don't have to choose what i'm going to
wear each day i already know
and it sounds boring but it really works
for me and i save a ton of money
and so you know i'm still saving money
when i can i don't see any reason to
waste it
so there's a lot of change in behavior
to save money i can guarantee you don't
need to buy
three coffees a day at seven dollars of
coffee that's a total waste of money
i see that all the time and people go go
and pay
25 for lunch how dumb is that i mean i
don't do that
you know i just it offends me
it's bad karma to just waste money like
that
so i'll bring some lunch with me i can't
stand spending seven bucks for something
that cost 18 cents to make
that's so stupid yeah you know i think a
lot of people
look at america united states as one of
the richest poor countries in the world
because so i'll give you an example my
grandparents
from the state of punjab they were
refugees because the state was severed
and they lost their homes
they lost their family they lost their
land they lost everything and my
grandfather came to his new home
running with no shoes on and so they
were raised with the discipline of
you don't need a bunch of stuff in order
to survive you kind of learn to live
with very little
and so i was raised with them and then
when i was going to school
i know just just the basic things like i
would i would go to lunch
with a brown bag and i would make sure
they had to take my brown bag home the
next day because i would use the brown
bag for the whole semester
you know it's a little things that you
know we're in such a rich country where
we don't realize that
maybe we're being wasteful and i think
you know is that
so it sounds like that's what you're
saying is we're spending a lot of money
on things we don't need we have so many
luxuries a higher standard of living
which is which is causing people to live
broker well the average salary in
marriage of
america is about 56 000 and so there's
no question in my mind you can cut ten
percent of your costs
you are wasting money on something
you're buying a third pair of jeans you
don't need you're buying a fifth pair of
sneakers you don't need
you're buying some crap you don't need
everybody buys crap because
our whole society is designed to get you
to spend money from the day you're born
but you don't need to it's not necessary
in fact less is more there's something
beautiful about having a minimalist life
and having things that you really
cherish
and that was also my mother's philosophy
she would save up for a whole year to
buy chanel jacket and buy nothing else
and i mean that was her whole thing i
want to own this jacket the rest of my
life and when she passed away there was
a huge fight amongst the women in the
family
trying to get her collection of chanel
jackets which she'd only buy one of
every two years
but she bought the highest quality items
and not a lot of them that was her
philosophy and i think that really works
so now it looks like you know someone
wants to become wealthy in this day and
age first thing you got to do
is you got to cut some of the expenses
second continue investing your money
just like your mother
told you to do your mother did and like
how you said
the third thing is now what about in
terms of making money because
you built your wealth as an entrepreneur
and
obviously now things are very different
because we're in a very technological
age if you were stripped of everything
all of your money today your fame
what would you do to
build rebuild your wealth
i would go back to what i know and you
know that's i'm a salesman i'm a
marketing person that's i've been my
whole life
i would go back and find a product or
service or a company that required a
good salesperson and i would go work
i mean that's what i'm used to i mean
i've been working you know i took some
time off right after the liquidity event
the learning company but i went right
back to work and never stopped
and today you know i'm very very busy
scheduled doing a whole wide range of
things but they're things i want to do
that i really enjoy
doing um but i'm basically at my core
a marketing and sales person so that's
what i would rely on
i think those are the hardest jobs in
the world because salesmen are the only
people and sales women too
that start at zero each month and have
to build back their business you always
start the next month at zero
and then you have to go sell again and
and you can't even have a company
without a great sales person you have to
sell sell
sell that's how it works what about
cryptocurrency a lot of people are now
jumping into cryptocurrency
do you think that cryptocurrency bitcoin
is the future
is that a way for someone to now build
wealth quickly
well it is but it's you know highly
valued now i have a three percent
allocation in bitcoin in my own
portfolio
i have five percent weighting in gold so
i look at it as a property
and it's performed very very well but
you know the point is
bitcoin is going it's a very very early
neison asset class a lot of issues with
it
the one that's cropping up its head
right now that people should be you know
concerned about is
institutional clients do not want to own
bitcoin mined
using coal to burn for electricity and
that kind of defines what
much of how bitcoin is mined
particularly in countries
like china where you know they're not
compliant on human rights issues they're
not compliant around tariffs they've got
all kinds of issues there
and so there may be a premium coming
into this market
where original virgin coin that's not
mined using coal
that's mined sustainably with
hydroelectric or some other form of
sustainable energy are going to be worth
more than the blood coin
mined in china which is where the
majority of coin to date have come from
i also see that now you've also jumped
onto youtube
welcome to youtube is is that a feasible
way
do you think for now someone who's
looking for a creative way to make money
to do that
i think so i think everybody that wants
to play
as an entrepreneur going forward after
this pandemic
has got to have a direct consumer
digital strategy
i mean even if you're just b2b business
to business you still need a digital
strategy the whole world is pivoted
to using technology to communicate with
each other and sell products and
services and so
you're going to have to learn how to use
social media how to actually build
websites or at least manage that
process so that you get something very
compelling for people to see your
product and service
and buy it direct from you that's the
new model all the companies that i'm
invested in that survive to figure that
out
and so that's a new change in the
american economy and also
there's no barriers to entry for that so
you're gonna have lots of competition
from mumbai
shanghai you name it if you're not
willing to work 25 hours a day eight
days a week they are
and they'll kick your butt you now have
been investing in
dozens of companies on shark tank how
many companies do you now
have an ownership or stake in currently
the portfolio is about 36.
so how do you manage a portfolio of
companies
that large we use a very simple
method we track sales and cash flow
because the private companies we don't
there's no share price to track
we look at discounted free cash flow
that's how we manage the portfolio and
we monitor we have a weekly call
amongst the management team of larry
ventures every tuesday morning had it
this morning
and we go right through our portfolio
the good the bad and the ugly because at
any one time of the portfolio that big
there's euphoric outcomes occurring and
also disasters happening it's like a
giant passion play
it's happening all day long i'm getting
calls of look our somebody wants to buy
our company on the other half we're
going bankrupt you know it's sort of
that's the nature of the ebb and flow of
of
the volatility involved in owning so
many companies in so many different
sectors but
you know overall it's a very successful
group of entrepreneurs
they use the shark tank platform to
reduce their customer acquisition costs
which is really magic
my job as sort of an investor is to let
the world know that i've made this
investment choice i have millions of
followers on social media it usually
helps the company raise more money
it works in a big symbiotic relationship
and
and we add a lot of value to these
companies and we expect to be paid for
it
so i think that the trend of
having multiple streams of income now
because now you you're invested in
dozens of companies
and each one of these companies are now
paying you that's a very
attractive thing i mean everybody loves
the idea of multiple streams of income
obviously one way you can do that is
through dividends
but because of shark tank i think a lot
of people want to be sharks
they want to be like you wha
what do i need or what does somebody
need to be a shark
maybe on a smaller scale like is there
like a certain amount of capital
somebody needs or how can somebody start
doing what you do
you know i have a bit of an advantage
because
companies approach me all the time and
say look would you like to
invest in this next round and i say i
have
you know your round means nothing to me
i i know what i bring in value
i know what happens when i invest in
companies i know what i can do to
to to get your message out and help you
sell product
but i don't do that for free so if you
want me to be an investor
let's negotiate a very attractive
package that aligns my interests with
yours and that may be through royalties
or warrants or convertible debentures or
straight equity or straight
debt there's a wide range of different
um
you know outcomes and structures but i
don't want to be viewed as just another
investor because i'm not and it may
sound arrogant but the facts are
i can change a company's trajectory just
using my team and my millions of
followers
to get the message out there not just
domestically but globally
and so you know i'm very very selective
on which companies i invest in i want to
be able to take it from this platform to
this one
and everybody benefits from that
including me and
as as a result i don't negotiate too
much i say this is what i think
i'm worth and if if you don't want to
pay that
i'm okay with it i'm just going to move
on to the next opportunity
and that sort of may sound arrogant but
the
my best sales people are the men and
women my ceos when someone comes to me
and says look
we'd like to make you an offer to invest
i said why don't you just talk to some
of my ceos and see what value i bring
and then you decide if my offer is too
rich or you don't want to do it
but you know i've got a great team i
work with i've been doing this for
almost 20 years
i have some great outcomes have some big
disasters i mean
you know when you have a portfolio that
large you're going to have a lot of bad
outcomes but you're also going to get a
few that are just stratospheric
huge hits and luckily those pay for all
your mistakes
that's again the idea of diversification
and so you know every day i'm examining
deals i look at sometimes two or three a
day
as i did today and you know most of them
we don't do because they don't fit but
when we find something interesting
we get right into it and we try and come
to an arrangement
with the ceo and put them into our
portfolio and do everything we can to
explode their business
you know it's interesting you you
mentioned your your mom
and the importance of dividends to your
mom and anybody who watches shark tech
knows
how much you like royalties is that
partially influenced
because of your mom or is there a
different reason why you are such a big
fan of
getting royalties out of your deals no
it's probably again for my mother she
always said
you need to get paid while you wait that
was her
mantra get paid while you wait because
either she owned a stock with dividends
or she owned a bond with interest
getting paid while you wait was her
whole thing
and never never spent the principal just
the interest that was the other lesson
she taught me so my portfolio
is like a chicken on a spit dripping
cash
everything pays me something each month
and that's how you know we perform at
the operating company we look at our
cash flows every single week
it works for me remember in venture
investing
it's not return on capital that matters
what matters is return
of capital you haven't made a dime until
you get your principal back in a venture
investment
and that's very hard to do so if i use a
royalty great
you know people say to me oh royalty why
don't you just do equity because a
royalty is even better than equity
when the company gets sold the acquirer
if i have a perpetual royalty on board
comes to me last and says how do we buy
out this royalty or how do we
incentivize you to work for us going
forward
and continue the royalty both outcomes i
really like
but i'm i'm staying in the game cash is
flowing as i always like to say
what matters in business is cash flow
just say it like that cash flow that's
what matters
cash flow exactly if you don't have any
flat
any cash flow it's no go you're not
going to make any money
it's that simple i love that i love that
so
a lot of people look at you on shark
tank as this
mean cold-hearted person i mean when i
told my mom that i was doing this
interview she was like oh
you're interviewing the mean person and
so i want to ask you
are you this person with a cold ice
heart
or are you a big teddy bear that people
just don't see on shark tank
well i'm the only shark that tells the
truth i i don't worry about your
your feelings i worry about your money
and i think it's so disingenuous
when you know barbara or laurie says
look
you go you keep going you know you keep
mortgaging your house
i'm not going to invest in it but i
think you're what you're doing is just
wonderful i don't say that
i say your idea has no merit it's going
to go bankrupt you're going to bankrupt
your family you're going to zero it's a
terrible idea
why don't we deal with it right now why
don't you take this behind the barn and
shoot it
and start something else because it's a
horrible outcome for you if you
completely put your your family in debt
because of your really horrific idea
now you may not want to hear that
message but it's still the truth
and if you think i'm bad wouldn't you
see what happens in the real world
afterwards
bad ideas go to zero whether i tell you
that or not that's just a fact so it's
better that i just deal with the truth
and this again goes to something my
mother taught me years ago she said
always tell the truth and you'll never
have to remember what you said and
that is why i do that you know it's it's
sort of
i don't have to remember the truth it's
going to be the truth when i told it to
you it's going to be the truth 10 years
from now
it's still the truth if you lie to
people you're going to get caught in
that line you're going to trash your
relationships with them so i'd rather
just deal with the
the trauma right there and then and then
they call me the mean one i'm i'm the
nicest guy because i'm the only one
telling you the truth
so the question i want to ask you now
about shark tank because you have been
very tough
on your negotiating deals what what is
your biggest
regret or kind of missed deal would you
say on shark tank
well you may not be surprised when i
tell you this but i don't have any
regrets and i'll tell you why because
with shark tank and
which is why it's i think so successful
we're going into our 13th season
i have no idea what's going to come
through the door in the next 20 minutes
no idea i don't get to see these deals
first but they're so incredible
each year they get better more unique we
have everything now we have technology
we've got you know consumer goods and
services we have mechanical products
we've got
so much diversity in the opportunities
that if i miss one i know in a couple
hours i'm going to get another one i've
just
it just there i have no regrets i've got
a
fantastic team i've had really
incredible outcomes i still have the
largest exit in shark tank history the
sale of plated
to albertson which was my deal for 320
million dollars
nobody's exited anything that with that
much before
or ever since we started shark tank so
i'm pretty happy
uh you know with the outcomes and i've
made plenty of mistakes
plenty of mistakes and so you know they
go to zero and that's tragic too i hate
when that happens but overall
i'm managing diversity in portfolio
which i think everybody should do
you know that's kind of the way it works
one of the reasons i became a
shareholder in start engine which is a
company that funds with crowdfunding
equity crowdfunding
and on their paid spokesperson is listen
i
i don't want just one deal you can go on
a start engine
and invest in ten companies put a
hundred dollars into each one because
you don't know what the outcomes are
gonna be
it's so serendipitous you need a
portfolio and that star gen
start engine has 400 000 investors plus
so it gets all the deals on their
platform and people look at them and
shop like they're in a grocery store
saying i like that i like that i like
that i like that
i'm going to build a portfolio their
products and services i understand
i'm going to diversify my risk that's
the whole idea of investing the way i do
so when you say diversification do you
mean investing in multiple companies or
across multiple different sectors so
some tech companies some consumer goods
companies apparel companies so
what does that mean both it's very
astute observation
i have diversification in both i have
investments in every sector there's 11
sectors in our economy and i have
multiple companies in many sectors and
and generally speaking if you look at a
portfolio of
many companies as i have and you try and
guess the winners you'll never get it
right
it's like trying to get the grid right
in march madness
the brackets you'll never solve for you
just don't
know you have to have diversification
and i urge
people that are going to invest to make
sure they don't just do one company you
just don't know what's going to happen
so let's switch careers
gears a little bit before we get to the
end i know you like nice things
and i know we talked about this earlier
you like nice watches
nice cameras nice wines
when is it okay for somebody to now
start splurging their money i mean we
talk about
you know the state of a lot of people's
finances right now
when is it okay for someone to go out
and buy themselves a ten thousand dollar
watch
or a new gucci purse
when is that okay you know again i'm
going back to the source of my mother's
advice she told me and i use this
philosophy and all the things i buy
when you know that that analogy of don't
buy a lot of stuff
buy very little stuff but what what you
do by make it very high quality and
treat it like an investment in your head
so when i buy a very expensive watch i'm
extremely selective
because i want that watch to appreciate
now i have many many watches i have a
very large watch collection but to me
it's an alternative asset
my watch collection is up 114 percent
year over year
because i buy very very selective pieces
and i'm extremely fortunate to be part
of that
global watch community that when a rolex
or a patek
or adimar pk or fp journey
or oh my god you know all these
different watch brands i'm
very familiar with them because i'm a
very active collector and i select my
pieces
and you know i'm wearing an ap right now
um
this watch is is uh not an ap this is an
fp journal actually and this is a
a very rare piece that is up about 80
percent
over last year so i've owned it for two
years um
fp journal is the living picasso of
of the watch world he only makes 900
watches a year you have to be part of
his society to
petition to buy them that may sound
really corny but i love to work with
that company
and you know to to build my calibers
across all their different designs he's
noted for his absolutely crazy
dials i mean you know people look at
this and say how do you tell the time i
said i don't tell the time with this
this is a piece of art
i use my phone to tell the time that's
always with me this is a and the whole
point is
this dial creates conversations i
remember i was flying to dubai and a
woman beside me
getting on the plane said that's crazy
that watch how can you tell the time i
said
you're talking about this watch we're
now in a conversation this watch has
done its job it's a piece of art and
you're enjoying it
and it's controversial for you i think
that's fantastic that's why i own it and
by the way
it's up over you know 80 percent this
year in value so all that's in my head
when i do that with guitars
i have a very large pen collection uh
there's you know there's
companies like moblaw which build
certain uh
pens for their collectors and they
preview them years ahead
so if you find one you really like and
you know i like to buy number 13 out of
98 pens
and i have some extremely rare pieces
but they go up in value that's my whole
point i don't buy junk
so if you think that way there's nothing
wrong with you know splurging once in a
while but if you're strategically
buying things that appreciate value
you're actually investing
and enjoying yourself at the same time
so you know
people come and look at my watch
collection because i you know
i love to talk to watch community but
i'm very
very strategic each style is unique and
has a story
interesting how much did you pay for
that watch oh
this watch was probably um i'm going to
guess probably 60 or 70 000. wow
yeah i think the issue so i talk about
this a lot on our youtube channel the
issue the
kind of concern that i have is when the
stimulus checks go out you have a 1400
stimulus check go out you see a line out
the door at gucci
and louis vuitton and we saw this
exactly happen when the 600
check went out gucci started putting the
600 purchase on display
and you see a line at the door as soon
as that stimulus check goes out yeah
that's that's that's tragic what people
should do is take
at least half of that and invest it in
themselves you put that into an index
fund and just let it appreciate over
time
i mean this is a once in a lifetime gift
from the government
why would you just piss it away why
wouldn't you take some poor i take all
of it and invest it
just forget about that money and let it
accrue over the next 20 30 years until
you retire
you'll be so thankful you did that i
mean you know
i i i don't think this was i think they
put too much money in the economy
actually because there's a lot of people
who have full-time jobs that are getting
these checks
why we're doing that i don't know but
the decision has been made is my point
you should take this opportunity and
invest it in yourself you're not giving
it away to somebody else you're
investing in yourself that's the whole
point
yeah i mean i think this is why a lot of
people are looking at it like a k-shaped
recovery you have some people that are
doing very well
in this economy they've benefited
because of the pandemic while others
not so much but everyone everyone is
getting the money whether you benefited
or not and it's really kind of creating
a
a strange system in our economy no
question
very strange and i think this is
something we got to think about because
it could be inflationary down the road
and you're starting to see that pick up
when you watch the tenure go from point
nine percent
to 1.7 that's pretty scary are you
worried about the long-term
strength of the dollar or or you know
you mentioned inflation
are you think do you think this is going
to have a a big impact on people's
ability to
afford life well i do worry about that i
mean this is so over stimulating and now
we're talking today about another 3
trillion in infrastructure that's really
really inflationary in my view
but you know again diversification i i
invest in canadian dollars american
dollars swiss francs
euros british pounds and bitcoin i mean
and i have gold as well i want diversity
that's the whole idea because i don't
know what's going to happen next
will the dollar be up will bitcoin be up
will the euro outperform with the swiss
franc
which it's done before become the you
know the fiat currency of choice you
just don't know
and that's why there's a lot of room i
would i would you know argue one thing
about bitcoin which you know i've spoken
of many times now
when i made my declaration i was going
to three percent waiting i got all these
calls from institutions saying do you
know where your coin was mined
and i said no um you know i've just
bought bitcoin they said well
we don't like coin mined in china or
anywhere that's mined using coal to burn
electricity
to burn to make electricity that's very
pollutive and
and so there's i think there's going to
be distinction around sustainability
around bitcoin mining
in the years ahead so the premium for a
clean coin virgin coin
versus a blood coin from china
interesting very interesting
i actually didn't even know that i'm
glad you brought that up so
the last thing i want to go over today
we asked our audience
our viewers what they would like to ask
you and so i have five questions
from our audience sure question number
one
from casey burns206 on instagram what is
the most garbage investing advice
you see out there on the internet
the get rich quick day trading stuff
again there's nothing wrong with it if
you treat it for what it is
it's almost entertainment but it's not
investing it's
really really hard to do that and make
money long-term doesn't mean you don't
learn from it
but it's not investing so that's i see
all that stuff all the time
you know use leverage borrow money to
trade that that's crazy i don't agree
with that
number two is from deepti rao on youtube
what three keys would you give to a
beginner investor
who is 20 or 30 years old to start
investing
number one never more than five percent
it lets you build a portfolio with a
minimum of 10 stocks in it
never let any one of those stocks be
more
then i would let me let me let me start
from scratch on that one
start with 25 stocks because that's
enough diversity okay
and then never let those any one stocks
be more than five percent of the
portfolio never let a sector
like technology become more than 20
percent and constantly keep
trimming as one goes through the roof
they have a tesla and all of a sudden
it's 10 or 20 or 30
of your portfolio trim it back to five
you still own tesla but you've taken a
lot of profit you've taken a lot of risk
off the table
and you've got more capital to put to
work in other stocks so i kind of like
portfolios in that 20 to 25
names and then using those rules five
percent in any one stock never more
and never more than 20 in any one sector
and then you get diversification those
are that's what i'd say
that's if you're going to pick stocks
yourself i much prefer to just pick
exchange traded funds etfs that's what i
actually use etfs
awesome you have an etf yourself too
don't you i do i have an etf company i'm
very proud of it
that's why i have it awesome and next
one from instagram
michael sabando one what should one do
to impress a shark quickly the best
thing you can do is articulate your
opportunity in 90 seconds or less learn
to explain exactly what you can do
in 90 seconds or less because it's
really about the opportunity
and then explain why you're the right
person to execute on the
idea because there's a million great
ideas and very few people can execute on
them
executional skills are rare great ideas
are a dime a dozen and lastly
know your numbers if you get for past
the first two
and you're on shark tank and you've got
the lights on you and everybody wants to
invest and then you don't know your
numbers
you deserve to burn in hell and i'll put
you there myself the most popular
question i got this was this was
asked dozens of times and i know we
talked about it today but we'll just
kind of go over it quickly
was by page 22 on instagram what do you
think of bitcoin
crypto and the future of bitcoin is it
going to crash
or is it going to take over our currency
no i
i think it's going to become a property
much like real estate or gold is
i'm not sure it's it's stable enough to
be a currency it's too volatile
for example people won't take large
payments in it most of the time because
they don't know if it's going to be down
30
in the morning but that may also resolve
itself over time right now the biggest
issue around bitcoin for institutions
because less than five percent of the
institutions that could own it own it
is basically the regulator which in most
countries like canada and switzerland
and france new zealand
are starting to relax the rules around
crypto because they know it's here to
stay
or that or we speculate that canada has
etfs now with bitcoin in it
and i think the us regulator will slowly
move in that direction but
also this idea of sustainability most
institutional investors have
sustainability committees esg committees
compliant committees around you know
things like human rights and all that
and i agree with that and so you have to
be compliant and so
you know coin-minded china which is
where the majority of bitcoin is mined
is not made on a compliant basis and so
um you know that's an issue and i think
it's going to become more and more of an
issue so you're going to see virgin coin
become more valuable
because you can't tell the province of a
coin you don't know where it's been you
know when it was born
but you don't know if it was part of a
nefarious you know
illegal scheme or whether it came from
china or not but that's why if you have
the providence and you know it's virgin
then it's more valuable i think that's
going to occur there's going to be two
markets for bitcoin
that's something to think about so i've
restructured my strategy i'm investing
in miners now themselves
and then asking them to pay me in in
virgin coin
so if you're if you're a miner and you
want to expand your operations
come to me i'll fund it and then you'll
pay me a royalty and virgin bitcoin
and that's the kind of arrangement i'm
building right now royalties
love it you got to have royalties cash
flow as you like to call it
and number five uh from masked media on
youtube
besides money what keeps you motivated
every day to get up
and keep working instead of just being
comfortable with where you are
well i i want to do things that keep me
really stimulated i'm very interested in
in
engaging in entrepreneurship i help many
entrepreneurs i'm very interested in
photography i'm very interested in
recording music
you know i have a passion for wine i
have a very big wine business i'm an
investor in over 20 vineyards
and so these things are things that
balance my life because i've always said
the best managers in business
have ying and yang they have the idea of
the discipline of business which is very
binary
either you make money or you lose money
but they also have the chaos of art
and that helps them become more creative
as they try and solve business problems
the greatest managers i know have a
little bit of both
they really enjoy something they're
passionate about music or they're
passionate about you know
painting or something but they're also
great managers so they can do the
discipline of business
along with the chaos of art combining
those talents they're the people i tend
to hire
i think they're great at sort of being
masters of of of achieving things
because they find different ways to do
it
and you require some discipline in the
arts to do that
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe i don't
care where you went to high school i
don't care the name of your dog
i don't care about any of that what i
want to know is
you know what can you do for me or one
of my companies to make
our job easier